silly question to start to highlight
some of the characters if each of you
got the opportunity to have a drink with
one of these characters who would be at
the top of the list the one you most
want to have a drink with but then I
also want to know who would be at the
bottom uh I would want to have a drink
with Hagerty cuz I know that uh wrong
answer safe answer you've met haen
before I I I have no WS like just
getting straight to it and being like
let's have a crazy time right now and uh
I mean I would you're saying a drink a
drink just drink is fine with Hagerty
God knows what's in that drink though
now you know what you just scared
me I would say trunk trunk he's just so
much fun and I always like to get Taco
Bell after a night of drinking and I
know he's up for that so I think trunk
and I are Kindred Spirits in that way so
who's the bottom of the list for you oh
bottom of the list I mean it's got to be
Paul unfort ately just because he
doesn't drink only because he doesn't
drink I love I love me Paul but you know
he's uh you know he's not the most fun
at least at the beginning of the Season
fair enough I was putting Paul actually
at the top of my list because I want to
give Paul a drink and like walk him
through the experience of enjoying it
and you know he's he's a character that
the more you go into the season you know
I find myself connecting more more to in
a in a weird way you know his his Stakes
actually have very just you know simple
you know human emotion of wanting to uh
you know be protective um at the bottom
of my list is probably Hagerty I'm
probably the opposite I'm scared of
what's in that drink Gomez is at the top
of my list I feel like it's a fair
balance between responsibility and fun
and then the bottom of the list has to
be Haggerty cuz can't trust them I know
but but you'll at least uh you know
you'll come out of it with the story you
may not remember the story though that
that is the Silver Lining right there
all right of all of the crazy things you
do in the show is there anything that
Netflix said no to that you wanted to do
and if that wasn't the case if that
didn't happen what thing that we do
actually see in the show were you most
worried that they would say you're
pushing it too far with this I I will
start by saying Netflix not only did
they not say no they challenged us to
make them uncomfortable and to go for it
uh in their words um when we pitched the
concept um our Executives there are
incredible um and they totally
appreciated the tone that we were going
for when they first saw the first day of
dailies they saw our vision even more as
it started to be reflective on screen
and as the scripts came in uh there
wasn't that are you sure you want to do
this it was oh my God I can't believe
you're going to do that and then it was
just firmly on us to be comfortable with
our own decisions uh and you know I
think I I wouldn't say we're regretting
any of them but we certainly there's
additional footage for some of these
moments that we could have been even
more not even more because I don't think
we were frankly gratuitous but we it
could have gone to a gratuitous Place
versus a shocking place oh I have so
many follow-up questions but I want to
make sure I squeeze this in first cuz I
might have heard about this on the bus I
heard about a really expensive
prosthetic that you were planning to use
but then the actor did not want to use
that prosthetic can you walk me through
what happened there so that was so see
Thomas Hal who you get to see quite a
bit of in the first episode of the show
uh it's the morning of He's supposed to
be filming that day and we had spent
$10,000 on a prosthetic for him to wear
in his nether regions and uh he calls me
that morning he's like you know what
he's like if I'm going for it I should
just go for it right like I I want to go
for it I I I don't need the prosthetic I
I'll go all in I was like that's great
news this is amazing Pony Boy GNA go you
know full frontal on our show okay as
great news
and yes yes lots of high but it was like
you know the I'll just say this you know
we like big audience reaction and we're
like this is something that people would
be talking about it's really fun so I
have I'm tasked with calling the studio
and saying to them okay well I know that
he went through the discussions with the
intimacy coordinator and he signed a
rider and he was planning to wear this
thing but he doesn't want to wear it he
says I'm not going to wear this so there
was this mad Scramble for them to like
get the lawyers you know wake up the
lawyers make sure that they like uh you
know adjust things in there so that he
could sign a new nudity waiver that day
and give some permission to go and uh
you know Tommy was willing to go for it
uh across the board and so was the whole
cast which is what made this this
experience so much fun oh you feel it
when you're watching this I feel like
there's no good transition way from that
point into something else but you guys
know I'm obsessed with Cobra Kai so one
question I did have for you did you ever
consider including any other actors from
Cobra Kai in the obliterated Ensemble
you know I think you know we really
didn't want to it's like you want to
keep your kids away from like the drugs
and the alcohol like kakai is is a very
you know you is a show every episode has
like morals at its core and obliterate
is a show that's all about a lack of
morals and and wild you know risque time
and so there was something like icky
about like having one of our you know uh
Cobra Kai uh actors in this world there
are there are a couple there's there is
a an Easter egg on the show that you may
have missed that one of our series
regulars actually appears in obliterated
I know who this is because I have
another question about her this is one
of my favorite crossover elements
because I was reading that Courtney
shadowed one of your D dors here does
that mean that at some point in the
future maybe she could direct an episode
of Cobra Kai season 6 or even
obliterated season 2 we we love the idea
of Courtney directing for us uh we're
not sure yet uh who's going to be
directing in uh season six of Cobra Kai
but she's definitely an up up incomer
when it on that side of the camera she's
very very smart very into story and uh
she's somebody who would be make an
amazing director and it was awesome to
have her shadowing and appearing in a
quick little moment uh and Courtney's
also so like so funny like off the set
of Cobra Kai she is like the one actor
that we were like okay she could maybe
be in this uh this dirty risque world I
can see that that would be that'd be a
good fit but also I feel like the less
crossover there is the more incredible
actors I get to experience through the
stuff that you guys spear ahead so
better off keeping them separate but you
know I'm going to try to squeeze in a
question or two about Cobra Kai season 6
I'll start broad with that at this point
are you basically ready to go is it just
a matter of things in the industry
smoothing out and then it is go time go
into production we were basically ready
to go when the writer strike began that
was our first that was our scheduled day
one of production um so the you know
writer strike went on longer than any of
us ever thought it would and obviously
the actor strike is you know prolonging
as well fingers crossed that any moment
now maybe by the time these words are
reaching people's ears uh it could be
over um the you know for the three of us
who share a hive mind and never stop
thinking and talking you know it it just
did give our minds a place to marinate
and um and come back into the writer's
room um as soon as the writer strike was
over with more ideas uh more you know
depth in terms of where we were already
going and um the room is just you know
running on all cylinders right now and
as long as the the actor strike ends uh
we will be back in production after the
new year I like to hear it I'm hoping
for it all right I saved my question
that's probably pushing it too far for
last so they can kick me out right after
with Cobra Kai season 6 being the end
what kind of closure can you tease for
the show and if it's not closure are you
going to leave the doors open for maybe
some spin-off series which I know have
been talked about in the past we will
never uh have give actual closure when
it comes to anything we love working in
the Cobra Kai universe so there's always
potential to uh revisit that world we're
certainly thinking about uh you know
other uh ideas within the Miyagi verse
and it's only a matter of time before we
figure out exactly which which direction
we're going to head but this season
people should be gearing up for we're
really excited about Cobra Kai season 6
we we're going to go out with a bang and
it's going to be uh an amazing
experience for fans of the franchise I
got all the faith in the world you know
that and then obliterated season 2
please abolutely
yes